bonsoir oui je dis moi je viens de
trouver un très joli poème va un poète
argentin yupanqui tu pourrais te le dire
je voudrais le dire aux enfants rires
oui vacillante et où je pourrai écoutez
moi aussi une médiation quasi via
un poncho de quatre couleurs couvre son
corps fatigué et un bourg f de cuivre
l'enfant est en train de rêver
pardonnez moi ma chère amie mais il me
semble que c'est à moi artistes inégalée
autant qu inspire époux est de tradition
et de choc quand on doit demander mon
avis sur ce petit poème me sont d'après
ce que j'ai cru entendre que les phrases
sont plates inégale
écoutez monsieur dit m moi je trouve ça
quand même rageant 10 mai leaf les
phrases et c'est à dire la façon dont
dont les phrases construites me semble
incolore et dire que du côté met ces 19
si vous le prenez comme ça moi je
préfère mon élection ne s'est pas vexer
non je ne n'y ait pas que vous ayez un
certain goût il sort des petites pièces
faciles mais seulement savoir le chili
selon monsieur du cinéma tout à fait
d'accord moi je préfère continuer ma
lecture et vous laisser avec juin parce
que moi je prends pour les anchois
qu'ils ont bien
merci beaucoup moins chère france
la tour esi jury
n'avait pu constater des noms mais je
n'ai rien entendu rien c'est naturel
chez moi la poésie jus il se fabrique
son acrostiches ni anicroches à l'aide
de métaphorique en belgique et de
litotes authentique c'est peut-être bon
les les méta chose au diabolique avec
des quatre mois d'ailleurs sa mort donne
faim je vais terminer mon gloubiboulga
groupe alors dites moi monsieur disait
oui avec tous vos trucs bizarres oui ça
arrive quand même à faire de jolis
poèmes et bien voilà une excellente
question julie bravo à des graves ou
françois je constate que vous vous
moquez de moi d'ailleurs mon dos oui ça
prouve que ma conversation n'est pas à
votre portée aussi je m'en vais mais
avant tout apprenez chers amis que chez
nous les gens de qualité
la poésie est une chose naturelle et que
lorsque nous sommes entre nous et nous
souffrons de ne parler qu'en vert il me
semble que je n'ai pas très souvent
entre nous mais vous savez moi je laisse
ma faute à moi si cette île isolée il
n'y a pas de jaux de ma qualité
d'ailleurs je je je vous maintenant je
vous quitte et c'est avec ennui que je
m'en vais rentrer et si cela me nuit je
n'accepterai salle les inconvénients je
pars me retirer dans mes appartements
c'est ce qui arriva le séminal depuis
quelques temps avec ses grands airs mais
moi il commence à m'énerver sérieusement
d'ailleurs je lui prépare une surprise
qui sera pas tout à fait de son ont fait
savoir oui c'est
plus tard plus tard
lalancette circuit
coûte julie c'est pas très facile à
trouver tu sais c'est faut que je me
concentre
tiens julie dit nous tempère l on a
dream j'ai continué à chercher
un poncho de quatre couleurs couvre son
corps fatigué et un bout rêve de cuivre
l'enfant est en train de rêver il rêve
que tiède et la neige que son tendre
légale et que le vent lui dit des
histoires de troupeaux et de bergers
petit indien s'est endormi et pour te
faire compagnie la rivière sans bords
aussi petit indien s'est endormi tout
près de sa porte parce le chemin passe
le chemin oui parce le chemin quand on
parle lui du temps on ira jouer comme il
fera froid
attention voilà monsieur nord et casimir
qui n'est pas encore là vous n'avez des
entreprises grosses à tout comme pour
une france pas et vous avez bien et tout
appris toutes appelées parker show
villiers
mes chers amis bonjour c'est avec le
soleil et un ciel sans nuage que vous
apparaissez dans notre beau jardin nous
en sommes heureux et ce serait dommage
de ne pas oublier nos maux de ce matin
dumas chère julie enfin du slow 2 auquel
heureux présage depuis déjà longtemps
j'attendais cet instant lire dans vos
yeux sont votre bon visage la joie de
retrouver des amis si charme
que se passe-t-il vous avez dans votre
langage 160 parlait voyons je ne vois
rien dans les propos du nil qui puisse
vous choquer ou vous faire sourire de
propos aussi courant il en invente mille
l'habitude veut qu'il vienne le doubs
les dire
je ne vous suis plus prêt de nous
accabler paf je sens qu'il se passe des
choses je ne sais trop ce qui se passe
ça mais je vois que monsieur du snob
quels que soient les efforts qu'ils
fassent ne peut comprendre tout ce
qu'ils demandent mes amis ne l'accablons
pas notre langage est trop choisi
efforçons-nous quand il est là d'oublier
toute poésie lorsque nous serons entre
nous nous parlerons de la lune du bruit
de l'eau sur les cailloux du soleil et
de la nuit brune ou
métro se couvrir de ridicule mais ça ne
se passera pas comme ça plus dure est la
coqueluche l'attend à la vengeance
casimir attention monsieur du jeune
homme arrive tu es bien compris
parfaitement compris
ah
quel beau temps aujourd'hui
je viens vous voir
aujourd'hui comme tous les jours
je voulais simplement vous dire
que j'avais quelque chose à vous dire
habib avait dit le monsieur dislab je
crois que j'y arriverai ni avec ce gros
balourd de casimir
quand je rencontre un ami
[Musique]
je lui dis
à ton ami
iman eu de très courant et jimmy
dis-je ima unesco à tes souhaits
quasiment
lima une trés curage et un hymne à une
iceta
malades non pas du tout il marine très
corrects ils valent une une gaine jamais
donné vite fait que cet avenir est
devenu complètement fou c'est pas
parce que tu madrid désireux arrête de
te moquer de nous orange compte une mini
guide louise en fait quasi dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe ouais ce que tu
nous lis clic je ferai ce que tu m'as
dit c'est tout moi mais oui tu m'as dit
quand tu verras monsieur du ce nombre
par lui enverra
est alors en vert c'est bien le
contraire devant droit
d'asile
[Musique]